aux saluts femmes ouais je suis chaud
bouillant à mes jeux barthez qui
m'appelait épisode très bien la chaîne
distribuée fait très attention à nouna
on a nous n'allons le viseur mais toi
aussi très attention mais quand même on
lui a donné des points là tout d'un coup
il a gagné des points en dû sentir isolé
mais critique touche pas à mon poste ils
ont dû dire c'est le qui influencent
internet ils ont compris le truc ils
sont ils font assez mettre dans la poche
bon vous avez réussi pour le moment mais
attention le vent pourrait tourner ça
vous continuez en fait c'est ça c'est ça
on a regardé mon du coup l'émission des
songes être à un coup d'oeil on verra
parlera peut-être positivement du truc
mais bon on verra quand j'ai ouvert le
chat which non je suis entré je suis
très bonne humeur en fait parce que ça
il se passe un truc fantasy pour un bon
il ya un stage au maroc après demain je
crois que tu es au courant de ça nous
sommes donc du coup aujourd'hui et
demain je ne travaille pas en fait du
tout je ne faut absolument rien donc je
suis d'excellente humeur
bonne humeur et en tire des trucs sur
l'album là tu passes la grave non pas le
montrer blitz c'était pas mal je peux la
montre et d'ailleurs on verra là ce soir
c'est le tournoi un tonton elle pendant
la petite demi heure
l'aéronef dommage l'ucm et d'hippolyte
de mon retard au temps sachez parlement
il ya que trois mais qu'un peuvent donc
fauqué mecs se bouge et s'inscrire au
tournoi comme d'hab mais c'est sûr que
pendant une demi heure tu vas faire de
l'explication d'inscription au tournoi
je pense mal an des huit là pour le
moins sur les crimes dont toi et moi on
ici on n'est que six ont été on était
huit là on est 6 ha dont moi donc on est
intéressant non mais bon enfin tu vois
je vais ouvrir la chaîne quick de gaming
j'espère qu'il y aura plus de monde que
sur ça j'en ai plus que simple c'est
génial mais a atteint faut que je change
le titre je suis idiot feu ouais on
n'est pas beaucoup
je pense que les mecs regarde le match
et c'est là commence à peine à l'oeil
mais qu'on ait que deux derbies tout il
me vient au classement vie du groupe
rien nous ne sommes pas des noms alors
on est douze arnould a d'ailleurs plus à
que la au maroc poker pourquoi je sais à
marrakech le vampire de demain du coup
c'est trop croisé les stagiaires on
essaiera stade échelle complètement
rongé de en plus je sais déjà dit mais
je vous mis au poker causés chaque camp
fait bonne mais je sais que je joue pas
moi je peux dire que je vous mais moi je
le dis je jouais au poker
bah je suis complètement objectif par
rapport à moi-même si tu veux en fait je
joue je joue à l'oma omaha hi lo c'est
un truc que quatre personnes jouent
beaucoup plus intéressant nouveau en
fait ouais enfin je savais expliqué je
peux enfin leveaux mieux jouer le haut
que le bas parce qu'en fait il ya
toujours un haut du bourg voilà en fait
sans jouer pour les 100% du pot je vis
ici et pas ailleurs des plus forts est
de peu d'être plus fort au prix serré
que c'est pas dur mon niveau et cheikh
sarr est que fout je crois qu'on le voit
dans tous les scream 1 j'en ai eu plein
les couilles de mal jouer aux échecs
quoi cannes algérien qui a commenté une
vidéo ce matin il savait pas qu'il y
avait de l'équipe d'algérie et époque on
de rugby du coup je vais envoyer la
vidéo je crois qu'il était très content
mais fantastique mais moi je les
regardais du coup mais j'ai adoré quoi
j'en ai plein les couilles de perdre ou
pu perdre
j'en peux plus les mecs je tends plus la
nuit quoi fantastique j'adore trop son
discours jeu
j'ai bien envie de le faire au stage au
début ouais si vous êtes venu au stage
en trois mots disco là pour le moment là
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'il ya que
trois personnes dans le tournoi je ne
suis pas sûr que le tronc et lieu ce
soir on décolle alors je sais pas mais
le truc c'est qu'en fait quand on n'est
pas sur leurs chaises points comme tv je
sais pas les gens n'ont pas le réflexe
twitch si tu veux toi par exemple talent
réflexe twitch web à propos des abris 3d
peuvent ni les dames et le truc sur
facebook des stream
ouais j'ai mis sur facebook bitstream
j'ai mis partout tout le temps qu à paf
le plus tard geste - comme la vie mais
bon ne pas profiter le fun d'être le
facebook chat ce point comme ils sont
très conventionnel vous fait réussi à
percer aperçu dans le quotidien dans
l'émission quotidienne de ce soir la
place d'iéna cellino les as we know me
l'on pense à la retraite un temps de la
knu jour quelques jours porte-bébé va
être content du tout wellstream à la
télé ça a une belle vie maintenant quoi
il ya elvis carter arrivé la berd à la
tv je savais pas trop là où les
fantastiques en fait ya plein de gens
qui ont dû voir ça en fait il ya des
gens qui arrivent à plomb des 19 face au
dehors devant lé petit à petit je pense
que je pense que en fait quand s'est
passé là et je pense que les gens devant
leur écrivait qui s'équipent qui
ces types de quel droit à l'écrit sur
son histoire déjà d'histoire j'ai déjà
écrit un voile j'ai eu à des mélodies
which machin très bien brûlures par
discorde
du coup de ce pas là mais en fait tu
toujours très bien ouais donc je pense
qu'on va lancer ray on va là on va
lancer la chaîne de gaming et je pense
qu'on va faire on va faire dans un
premier temps le civilisation si ce
vraiment un choc va commencer par ça jeu
qui pense de plus en plus ça mais ça va
être fantastique je sais pas si je dois
jouer un peu avant salle où si je
découvre le jeu avec les gens en fait
civilisation six dents longues heures
paralyse je ne veux plus voir tout est
parallèle très attention à 28
beaucoup de personnes
entraînement
voilà tu es très tranquille au maroc
était conscient quand je vais arriver
samedi ça va être la peine est
totalement fou j'étais hyper stressée je
suis pas sorti jarry fait en fin de
droits mais photos des zones où elles
avaient dit qu'ils poussent un peu
bizarre quand même dans ce torchon pas
trop en formant des gros stage avec 20
kg ou connaît comme moi mais c'est pas
vraiment les sorties c'est juste que
c'est juste que je suis tout le temps là
mais le problème c'est que tu commences
à joe cocker ses marges mais qui est là
qui est là allez viens elvis et leïla
oui combien qui sonnèrent vanille 5 et 2
millions mais oui c'est toi regarde
regarde oui oui je suis là qu'est ce que
si vous voulez meubles pour des clubs du
top 14
je ne sais pas quoi faire ce soir pour
mme angle est nouvelle elle faisait
surtout si ça n'a pas trop plu
la passe à la caméra il m'a dit ouais ça
aux screen de merde y'a pas assez de
monde me barre moi je suis venu boire un
verre de lait je vous emmerde
bon il est là y regarde il regarde un
peu il fouine
voilà voilà maintenant il a assis voilà
il est allé s'asseoir devant le
réfrigérateur
voilà il est devant le réfrigérateur en
train de dire bon batteur il enfin être
un tournant tout autour m
l'entrée de ce truc à marie revient le
voir
non il est parti voir ma femme
il a compris quoi l'abruti fait ces
vidéos elle va l'allumer mg / voit qu'il
a essayé sur wiiware est il paisible il
attend il attend ma femme qui est sur le
balcon en train de parler à ses parents
et il s'est allongé sur le lit
tranquille
un choc
ça c'est qu'il ya perpignan dax à 21h
famille à la pro d2 qui reprend ses
droits
le groupe veut comme on descend on va d
inscrire dans le pendant open à
l'expérimenté 6
on est six balles jouffre healy qui
parlent pas changé le chef non mais
j'aime bien ce chat il hyper sympa et
super bien le chat s'était de l'apers on
t'en fous complètement que j'ai remarqué
que les fêtes j'ai déjà fait il te
regarde
il ne comprend pas à quoi ça tient
est il prêt pour une demi heure
d'explications pour s'inscrire à man en
fait le truc c'est qu'aujourd'hui comme
on n'est pas sûr sur chaise comme tv ben
en fait mais c'est marrant quand même
parce qu'en fait j'ai regardé fab
je vais être complètement honnête avec
toi je n'ai pas été assez honnête avec
toi au niveau de twitch j'ai analysé fin
tu sais que quand je commence à
m'intéresser à des trucs je suis assez
fou de ce point de vue ben oui ça ça ça
m'énerve
enfin c'est comme les trucs développe
machin je considère comme un malade est
donc aujourd'hui j'ai essayé de lire
entre twitch machin youtube et tout est
en fait il ya plus de gens sur twitter
que sur twitter structure youtube pour
les live mais pas pour les échecs parce
qu'il ya personne qui fait des échecs en
france est donc une nouvelle fois on va
être à la pointe du truc en fait on est
en échappée l'arrêter le peloton des
joueurs d'échecs tahiti qui sont
derrière vous êtes déjà sur twitter quoi
d'être numéro pour de concret bitstream
tweet cheveux non je vais faire glisse
ring hemmings qui a déjà un bis rim
twitch mais ça en anglais je veux pas je
veux pas je parle je leur vitrine gaming
dans google et chaîne youtube aussi
ouaip il y aura peut-être
je demanderai à manu s'il veut
s'il veut passer faire un peu de hearst
au nez tout ça sera une chaîne un peu de
joueurs d'échecs qui veulent faire du
gaming
je suis moi je suis complètement nul
mais avec toi on fera des stream drôle
quoi ou d'erreurs cooper bas c'est à
dire que ça se peut qu'on sait pas si on
fait du hadj of empailleur l'objectif
sera peut-être de suicide et une
civilisation un moment donné quoi aller
les combos coutrot réussite détruites et
propre bâtiment je t'emmerde
ou alors on va le faire le players and
online est un jeu qui est pas mal où il
ya 150 personnes qui ceux qui sont
développés sur une map et l'objectif
c'est d'être le dernier survivant
c'est très intéressant ça nous venons
voir une bonne concurrence avec le
grenier oui non en fait on n'a même pas
ici de concurrence et grognon ah bah
c'est sûr que la ctu la concurrence
générique des dates a plus de mal là
mais bon d'un autre côté c'est plus
motivant en fera de trucs et août ce
sera marrant fin on va pas faire ça à
temps plein pas cette force d'antan mais
j'ai bien envie de me marier avec les
gens d'arrêter de parler tout le temps
des chèques la planète c'est ça me
frustre d'avoir toujours l'échiquier
vers un côté là non mais pas dire qu'ils
soient verts qu'il soit rouge c'est pas
la couleur
le jeu offre non mais enfin j'adore les
échecs c'est juste à force de faire que
des échecs j'ai l'impression d'un vote
situé à force d'être le connard qui fait
des échecs c'est pas le mot connards qui
mise alors je dérange là dedans le cône
en cours ouais un connard situer même
adjectif indéfini un connard parmi tant
d'autres guillaume meurice tout à
l'heure c'était très marrant et un mec
qui lui disait si tous les connards
aller défiler dans la rue aurait peu de
gens pour regarder la manif fortement
j'ai dit oui c'est complet pour vous est
ce que tu as dit
alors kévin à quelle heure me demande ce
tower 20h35 place de wolfe des illuminés
18 minutes normal électorale commence je
pense pas jouer cette fois c'est
peut-être que les joueurs pourraient
fermer vers ce qu'il faudra qu'on fasse
un de ces quatres c'est les et chacun
quatre là interviews sont sortis ça mais
on fera peut-être au maroc comme ça on
fera une vidéo ce sera une vidéo quatre
échecs à quatre on se mettra deux sur
leur union se battre à camphin ce que tu
peux pas tu peux pas jouer à deux pas du
tout été dans un truc vendôme tu peux
admettre avec des gens que tu connais
comme ça on se fera un truc qu'on le
fera découvrir au maroc comme ça ça nous
fera ouais bah on découvrira ensemble
maroc je connais pas non plus j'ai
jamais joué donc on fera une vidéo
découverte
on découvrira avec les internautes fn
porter un jour mais j'ai une bonne fini
j'en avais marre c'est trop long je
voulais des partisans des échecs
classique à 4 avec ont six heures se
fout seniors avant cela paris puis 17
apparemment ça fait moins des choses
plus intéressantes à 4 à 4 que tu aux
échecs
alors ouais pas mal de gens qui
regardent leurs deathmatch avec à gagner
avec simone contre ping
je sais pas pour qui je suis d'ailleurs
peut-être plus tôt pour saimone quand
même encore aux normes c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas le courage de venir jouer
contre nous ils s'organisaient truc
entre eux on sent on sent qu'il manque 2
de piment jeudi
vous avez des sales trucs mais en fait
je pense que tu les défoncer les deux on
ne me joue mal ben franchement je le
crois en toi tu arrière pyrite il est
pas content sur youtube il dit boom dans
l'émission quotidien de yann barthès ou
nv elle était invitée tu as lu la voir
aussi que du lavoir aussi louis nice a
par contre j'aurais pu citer le nom de
ta chaîne c'était la moindre des choses
bougent il est pas content quoi doit-on
être aussi maintenant contre contre tout
cas fin de ton être en guerre tu n'as
pas cité le nom
ouais je ne cite pas les noms des médias
qui sont plus grands que toi
[Rires]
son père étant insupportable
j'adore être en mode insupportable ça
fait trop marrer
alors est ce que tu veux ça tu veux
savoir un peu qui joue demain puisque
sega touran beijing la de pékin et il ya
des beaux quarts de finale ouais il y à
dimitrov contrebas autistes à goutte
show 10 euros il ya nadal isnard ça peut
être chaud parce que là il peut avoir du
mal contre des joueurs contre isner gros
service et qui joue tout sur une balle
de nadal et djoko murray de certains il
ya kyrillos contre d'arsys médard 6 il
joue peu de familles jouent rarement
bien les contres ils jouent bien ils
jouent vraiment pas mal donc j'ai pas eu
tout à te faire là l'exploit pour nos
amis belges et ya roublev contre sierre
f mérou l'axé c'est le petit jeune la
halle us open qui avait bien joué et
aujourd'hui l'éliminer berdych quand
même et à pékin a à tokyo pardon il ya
schwartzmann johnson bonjean une tonio
on s'en fout il ya gasquet goffin
intéressant si leach contre harrison
moquer ses bijoux gros favori est
sujette à contre mannarino est sujette à
j'avais vu qu il a fait des bons
résultats dernièrement que ce qu'il faut
c'est un japonais il est 40e mondial
ces quelques bons résultats
et on est au tournoi féminin wta beijing
j'ai vu le match thaler wozniacki
kvitova
je peux te dire que kvitova envoyer du
lourd
ça tape fort allez on n'a absolument
rien à faire du coup tu vas jouer elle
joue of
elle veut faire un point gagnant tout le
temps en fait c'est un peu comme
ostapenko elle en a absolument rien à
faire il n'y a pas de plaintes et d'ici
peu macho man non non ça ne sert à quoi
et c'est ça le tout le temps en fait
c'est que ça c'est beau mais même si tu
as deux mètres en dehors du court je
m'en fous bout on n'a que sept joueurs
il ya six rondes je sais même pas si le
tournoi va se lancer en fait si on monte
sûrement reste la même en deux temps
pire sinon je ferai des médecins mais
c'est dommage quand meme qu réussissent
pas à voir du monde pour ce tournoi du
jeudi quand même c'est incroyable je dis
donc je sais pas aujourd'hui je
comprends pas pourquoi j'ai même fait le
post facebook j'ai tout fait les mecs
et même quand on n'est pas sur chelsea
tv d'habitude on monte à 40 50 personnes
je sais pas peut-être aujourd'hui pour
une raison x ou y
les gens ne sont pas sur internet je pr
re journée le matin le quotidien et son
amour au port de l'atc film le plus loin
possible c'est quand même ouf de passer
à 2 enfin c'est dingue quand même quand
il pense sans nulle bas
moi j'ai fait cette chaîne de base tu
vois enfin je ne pensais pas fin pour ce
bol banon met fin jeu enfin je pensais
même pas que les gens me regarderait en
fait j'ai vraiment fait ça au début tu
as comme ça juste pour m'amuser pour
voir
jean ramière qualifiant familier du mal
a eu du mal à comprendre qu'un fan des
échecs puisse ne pas lire ce livre par
une unique de maxime mais je vais te
dire que je ne vais pas lire
probablement le retrouver en fait moi
y'a plein de trucs que je veux dire que
j'ai pas lu en fait
et j'aimerais bien le lire si tu veux
mais c'est pas dans mes priorités
[Musique]
non mais faut que je me cultive tu vois
je voudrais un peu lire vous sauver vous
le talent de rousseau et voltaire en
fait si le temps mais mon rêve difficile
à comprendre quoi cet opus salut les
gars de chasse aux puces on va le voir
après demain je sauvais chasse aux puces
à faire feu de tout bois
dès dimanche matin va falloir attaquer
quoi l'état doit perdre dimanche à peine
je propose qu'on fasse honneur ou non
match de samedi soir face à ces petits
meetings l'europe a le plein parce qu'il
ya des délinquants à un peu tard cette
chaude concédé à lyon ce matin
peut-être intéressés mais en concédant
où on va maintenant tu tu dors meary un
petit maillon fort de deux enfants avait
peut-être les gens avides profiter de
leur après-midi connaissent pas
marrakech me fait envie d'aller voir des
trucs cela les directs dont la visite
d'un côté physique c'est peut-être pour
ça tu être ma vie et mon frère je sais
pas on verra avec les gens on discutera
de la tête ils veulent faire 10h 12h et
13h 15 heures ou quelques jours sa
fidèle d'un autre côté 8h30 bouté dans
le truc après tout on apprenne
tranquille pour aller faire le fou de
partout quoi dans les plats l'option
passons ce qui est sûr c'est que l'après
midi je pense tu pourras me trouve au
coin de la piscine
c'est très possible qu'il n'y a pas le
sage ou sinon le matin ce que le soleil
et la piscine as un truc qui me manque
tu vois la piscine
si quelqu'un c'est en tant que cannois
que je parle
ninja il dit tu vas jouer km non pas du
tout on fait faire par un guy traut des
chats qui hier peu de monde aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs avec manu ouais ouais c'est
différent ouais c'est pas un grand match
hier françois parce que c'était pas mal
principaux car aucun suspense ouais
non mais on verra mais toi en fait de
toute façon tu fais toi tu auras bien
dormi toute façon photo tu t'en fiches
en fait du truc de matin après midi et
tout l'été sur place en fait de bronze
je n'ai pas à voir mais il en dit déjà
visite puisque moi je participe à la
visite insolite mais toi tu vas
visiteurs ici ou pas moi je moi je suis
là au moins au moins deux fois moi je
vais de toutes les visites en jeu faire
feu de tous a pendant la visite
ça sent que je vais filmer mon blog
pendant les visites
[Applaudissements]
après on peut créer une scission dans le
groupe quoi ce que faire le matin
l'après midi tout le monde s'engueule
fantastique et après tu fais une session
avec toi même toi tu veux le matin et
l'après midi quand on peut plus quoi
dans scission totale
je suis mise en échec par vous je
regarde un peu des vidéos de psycho ceci
tout à l'heure que j'avais le temps que
j'avais à faire et bien qu'il fête ses
trente et il m'a écrit que tu m'a écrit
tu vas dans les technologies quoi ah oui
non c'est les anciens messages d'une
part les technologies la maxime qui m'a
écrit aussi tiens bout
c'est le droit de dire ce que we may cry
la perruque à frac et à frapper ça tu
m'a réussi
beaucoup me laisserais où j'étais
complètement débile avec la période en
plus âgés oui ils ont 10 ans 10 heures
s'il a l'air plus conclut ce soir là 200
points alors c'est un komodo y tue ses
proies parce qu'elle est entrée chez moi
je suis déçu car bonne humeur en fait
aujourd'hui j'ai déjà très bonne humeur
avant en fait je suis super content en
fait je peux pas expliquer pourquoi
c'est parce qu'il ya le maroc là qui
approche et ça m'excite quoi ça excite
afu en fait je suis très heureux la
belle vie s'il en pls total dont il
attend devant la porte pour sortir la
personne qui allait ouvrir il s'allonge
devant la porte de sortie de chez moi là
et qu'on met dedans allongé devant ils
diront s'il ya quelqu'un qui sort tu le
vois je le vois sortir ou l'acquitter de
ville c'est la bonne oui mais attention
les gens qui écrivent sur 10 sur les
gens qui écrivent partout c'est la bonne
humeur meurs meurs meurs
je sais pas quand chaque point comme va
faire ce que je leur ai demandé de faire
les tournois et les tournants du let
avec ces conneries title tune et du
bullet
je leur ai dit ce serait génial pas
serait fantastique créé le buzz shirt
vegan c'est génial tu peux approuver le
font pas c'est dommage
ce serait drôle jours le bullet c'est la
vie de façon
en revanche on fait un truc très drôle
c'est qu'ils ont déposé le nom de 6
check point xxx très savoureux
mais enfin c'est ce qu'on fera des
vidéos du maroc de joeurs fera peut-être
frappé tous genres à quoi un truc de ouf
la ce jeu-là de 2 à 4 4
tu sais que plus les pions mois des
promotions et de l'échiquier je
connaissais pas cette règle pas si
génial
morin qui tout simplement débile pendant
que j'ai patron d'hp l'égard de chaque
côté ou l'art de rien fait mais je pense
que ça va être un jeu pour nous ça va
être un jouet de fouine je pense plutôt
pas mal de trucs c'est bien ces jeux se
font la guerre que tu gardes tes pièces
non tu vas pas de point à temps non non
et je pense que tu de cette j'ai peur
que tu sois aussi mauvais copies de sacs
atlas est ce que tu me dis ça me fait
peur la non tu t'en fous tu m'as pas de
fourneaux mais tu t'en fous tu as tes
pièces banon c'est de marquer des points
un coup de fil ouais le mec qui a trouvé
des stratégies quoi le stratège fabien
les visages ski mais c'est quoi le but
du jeu après dix minutes c'est génial
sur une bonne note et les maths et les
espèces qui dégage tu marques de fait
installer point que tu as marqué n'étant
marquera pas plus à longny absolue et en
ligne attire absent sur la vierge lui
tomba bystrica vraiment une très bonne
idée e
pour moi c'est bien mais avec l'acquis
tombé tard à temps a proposé un match
absolue du coup à tient à temps je
regarde une partie de la somme tout
assez fantastique sa partie de 4,5 à
relire froid f6 faut que tu apprennes il
connaît pas qui les prend le 5e
il avait poussé quatre mois je vais lui
apprendre que je vais lui écrire ce soir
je lui ai écrit voilà on est en train
suit une partie d'absolu en ligne
progressive mais il va bien il est 1070
la première fois qu'on s'est rencontrés
l'été 880 ou 9 cents il progresse il est
même ses pièces correctement et ou non
petit à petit ce petit l'oiseau fait son
nid
l'ancien des gens qui savent pas comment
s'inscrire à ces morts là trop tard face
en main
on est dix est quand même un finalement
dacia salle il fait de même 5 là on est
bien la nef 5 avait lieu cette dame mais
aussi s'il a peut-être aller le matin en
force à l'eab ceux-là les petits bouts
il a fait d'un médecin cas les batwa la
dame en a eu six allers approche toi
absents olé olé olé allait pas toi petit
bout il a mis la dame le 6 mai il joue
pas mal sérieux il progresse bien c'est
cool à les cavaliers prend bats toi si
tu masquer les problèmes si ces dames f7
c'est pas si mal faire
allez allez justifions prend boon a cédé
6 ha il a fait fou prend mais menace
sourde à 9,7 maths mais c'est plus fort
avec le cavalier je pense qu'il faut
quand même aller faire de même cette
fois aussi sous on va laisser finir
absolue on va les voir notre tour dans
le tournoi a commencé à aller je vais
voir je vais voir cochon et l'efs g1
c'est une écossaise
c'est chaud c'est très très doux comme
partie intégrante de cochon et l'efs
peut-être f40 ses bienfaits peut-être
fou des trois tu développes petit rock
tour 2 5l faut 2 c'est peut-être un peu
ça va encore les fouets f3 on protège le
pion rock on met la tour en 1 e 1 pas en
d1a les cochons élèves à léonie pour la
surprise
on est pour la surprise fab lourd c'est
le petit poucet lp quesniaux poussette
tâche pas si tentants et demi c'est très
mécontents la liberté des chèques à
quatre roues brouillon mais là quand je
suis à l'aise pour le moment il est très
très bien beau mais sain qui fait
exactement le plan que j'ai dit je sais
pas s'ils écoutent le scream en même
temps ou pas mais en tout cas rien qu'en
mettant le bon plan place aux échecs
déjà tu t'es très très bien quoi nos
échecs souvent avoir le bon plan la
bonne vision du jeu ça suffit déjà à tu
vas faire du gros progrès
même ton rare vient de commencer qui la
guident les gi la guide du coup elle
s'était un peu en retard pour le mois
prochain comme et des fonds ont fait des
tournées au milieu où la hausse tarifs
qui craque complètement
il va penser à une surprise en cochon
elf peut-être un peu sous-estimé son
adversaire oscar if aux carafes coup je
regarde cochon et l'efs pièce blanche
contre oscar af caisse noire
et ça se bat n'a malheureusement
cauchois élèves il a fait un peu
n'importe quoi avec sa tour mais les
versements de fou prend f3 et vous
prendrez des faux pas sera le temps de
faire ses preuves ces intermédiaires
haye le voi pa ay ay ay ay ay ay bon il
a quand même des pions l'os peyronnet
c'est pas mal
elle avait juste une pièce de plus avant
donc pour sa 7ème et peut-être faire ces
trois baies quatre noms pour enfermer le
fou dans votre attention
sa tournée attaqués dont ça se passe
oulalala la fab on ne menace pas à cet
ail
dommage pour lui facilita il a fallu
pousser 5 la double attaque assez
horrible du coup la tour sur lui outre
l'euro un peu 5les des capteurs mems
centralisation n'est vraiment témoin à
cet enchaînement fable à 5 tours à cette
fougue et quatre là il nous a fait mal a
laissé 4 on pousse le pion fab et après
royales d'europe et en quatre échecs
aussi quoi tu fais des promotions milieu
de l'échiquier eu le temps d'avoir les
deuxièmes sûr que le coup de pied de
coin c'est que le jeune ninja jeune
ludwig hammer il est fan du jeu ils
adorent temps mais c'est très mauvais
on va passer trois savamment d'avant
montée droit quand même faire ses cadets
comme ça logique au final la souque la
tour était bien passée à le protéger de
cavale et là j'ai pas se faire [ __ ] en
est tour à tour ces deux atouts pas
parce qu'un pote la loire autour des 8
enoch fr bref de roanne 3 rapidos quoi
venir poser sa volée dans les 38 ouais
da kg babou et sa force a déjà commencé
20h15 le début du tournoi chaque semaine
on vous dit 20h30 voilà donc c'est sinon
ça commence à 20h le stream dans mon à
l'antenne amateurs on dire peu n'importe
quoi pour une demi heure pour n'importe
quoi en fait il relève de rôle trois des
quatre années tu montres leroy au centre
et après tu pousses les pions torah 5 et
dans tous les messages incroyable en
fait c'est air de parenté le rang final
c'est vraiment une année rare que je
retrouve très souvent fabre des jambes a
été de monter le roi où on sait ça je
sais pas pourquoi mais je pense que
faire b53 a fait à 3 protège champions
montouroy le bal un truc c'est qu'il ya
un droit qui va arriver qui va venir en
cinq temps des cats et il va venir en
russie ce c'est horrible en fait il va
tout perdre chez vos amis lors des
finales en fait c'est ce qu'il ya de
pire pour le joueur amateur il fonde
bien mieux de jour en jour et tactique
des machins et même des joueurs qui
peuvent avoir des travaux xi déjà l'on
peut très vite les rugbymans équipe mais
un superbe à montpellier maintenant
qu'il ya un très bon esprit pour
montpellier d'ailleurs l'essayer c'est
très bien ma mission exit ya donc en
fait il a toi dans les échecs des
régions mais c'est l'histoire plus toi
et en fait quand il joue il est assez
dangereux dans le jeu quoi laquelle
prêter de l'argent des petits sacrifices
des matchs chaque attaque pas cool
merde et que tu conseilles changez-vous
une finale bon après tout d'abord
expliqué donc maintenant ils commencent
à faire des trucs montée droits extra
mais effectivement en fait
tiaret quoi marc est un peu ce qui s'est
passé 1 c'est un peu le carnaval des
erreurs alors que jouerait bien joué
j'avais déjà plus d'avoir subi ce que
j'ai vu avant c'était bien à brooke est
il une enfilade hypothétique s'explique
la finale était très simple à faire même
pas de faire préfèrent acheter à
blizzard vous fixé trois plans bassam a
maintenant il y avait 4 3 là déjà il y
avait quatre échecs kf3 qui était
pénible mais là c'est froid dans son
droit j'ai conservé mon corps mais moi
aussi j'ai 6 3 5 1 il veut cacher
rigoureux 4 quel carnage violateurs
basse pas encore finie tue-tête encore
faire tour f si ce n'est pas subjectif
man tu peux encore faire mieux avec toi
et si ce jugement qu artiste au même
sort de feu
ça a tout changé de nom mais peu mais
[Musique]
oui oui n'ont pas raison à f2 a gagné
mais même toit j'ai quatre étoiles 5
wabush à tanger l'assedic à la cif est à
6 c'est nickel ouvrage de et à 6 juillet
d'abord on est rangée de la tour des
rôles en grh un des sujets que toi tu
sens que chacun porte
voilà toutefois froide fait rage et de
tuf et nul n'a pas annoncé qu'il a plu
tant il n'y a pas de rage ou à plus de
deux secondes mais là on fait même
tourcoing f2c nul à feu même si tu perds
à six et la finale depuis un lustre et
nulle part la tour f 5 échecs mais bref
2.230 ouais mais ça c'est vraiment
[Musique]
défense passive avec courage de la boc
ils bougent leur seconde que des coûts
des primes ou en vélo tour c'est d'eux
que ça ait façon tu as passé de temps
même si fait que des prénoms que tu peux
pas y arriver même revient d'ailleurs
mais à perdre je vais faire je vais voir
des 16 des second et faisait donc partie
pour tous surtout les pins pour aller
gagner demain marrakech
il reste grande
bonjour je viens d'arriver quelles
thématiques et ben c'est le tournoi du
premier jeudi du mois
on habite stream mais qui est déjà parti
dans leur camp tu pourras pas le jouer
mais tu peux regarder
voilà l après-crise tatung donc ça qu'on
travaille tard 35 chaque premier jeudi
de chaque mois
travnik à tout moment est venu pour solo
de quatre pièces où on peut hésiter non
c'est mon seul en solo dans 26 noms
seraient punis parce que si tu as deux
mecs qui sont solo et de mecs qui jouent
ensemble c'est un peu ripple je regarde
regarde gauche à nous donner vos meubles
en n'omettant pas même temps une zone
talend a assez
bon du coup sa première forme amour de
stage j'ai tout je peux montrer la
caméra web d'échiquier encore
l'emballage et l'egypte y est comme 16
points corps vert et blanc ils sont là à
voilà ça va enora l'aï évoqué pendant ce
mandat je parle des vallées sèches a
pourtant tf1
mais il ya là et on a aussi s'ils ont vu
leur accouplement dames 1
l'emballage est là il ya les piles qui
sont prêtes à être utilisées en
pronostics ces clubs d'échecs d'agadir
kit année où la coupe du matériel non
dangereux de très cool mais ils sont
contraints de faire un stage au maroc ou
pas d'ailleurs
wax avant que tu vois du coup je dois
peut-être s'il ne tenait dimanche on
échange les lois si je peux faire un
petit truc pour eux on fera donc
germaine d'un point de vue général et
saisissent tient à ses coups il ya des
mecs qui viennent nature il vient de
faire le truc au maroc et tous sympas ça
développe quelque part un peu les échecs
au maroc dans l'esprit tu vois où ils
sont elles sont si votre collègue la
fédé c'est un peu le poil de partout
dans le monde et leur président là c'est
un problème pendant plusieurs années
aussi la papier la cotisation les apu et
l'ofii mauvaise passe toujours des trucs
et donc ok il essaye de mettre en place
mais voilà trouve toujours précaire la
situation
c'est intéressant sais c'est pas mal à
ce café gros chat quand il a fait la
petite série il a dû le classique qui
avait prend 17 je peux pas reprendre du
cavaillé puisque tu as dame est cloué au
collégial à damas damas derrière et du
coup tu peux doubler les pions mais
maintenant en fait il faut il faut jouer
il faut jouer sur ce roi fab
ce serait peut-être pas mal de faire dam
des trois fous d un fou ces deux oies
[Musique]
pâturant forte qu'on puisse manger froid
comme ça même à 4
tu vas dès qu'un 2e franck leroy 3
portes la mer en face mais pour le coup
la première au maroc en fait pas trop de
chance en ce moment il ya moins de
thouars un gars box est fleurissaient il
professé 4 que j'avais déjà joué
plusieurs fois une fois marrakech une
fois qu'ils achètent plus où il ya
chefchaouen soit toujours à la hausse en
juillet aux tournois dans les montagnes
il y avait un super vite à rabat mais là
il ya plus mais j'avais joué il ya deux
trois ans mais c'était vraiment pas
renié mamediarov chira la mine
je sais plus qui avait beaucoup de coups
ce soir devant m andré lindsey vonn est
la reine ou alors seulement l'attention
après je suis pas sa balle et des gamins
sont les vôtres je pense tout bloquer ce
truc dans ce moment difficile
et en plus le problème c'est qu'ils
paient pour les joueurs aussi d'aller
voyager pour répondre à l'étranger audi
vise à être comme ça donc il soit trouvé
un peu bloqué tu vois n'a pas voir le
pape était de beaucoup de bourges ça
peut ça me défoule j'espère que tout va
s'améliorer s'arranger qui pourront
refaire organisé tous les tournois comme
c'était avant parce qu'il est quand même
le bouton noir et les voilà il ya un
potentiel et des joueurs très très
passionnée par le jeu ça c'est clair
voilà monsieur dommage quand tu manques
de pratiquer un moment c'est toujours un
problème
c'est à dire c'est qu'avec les mains
j'aime bien le voir à chaque tombée ces
quatre choses peuvent être mais
peut-être 3 mai sur sur ces 4 et
peut-être d'un match 3 novembre pour que
je ne retiens tout reprend g20 a changé
les ont poussés tous ces visages
inauguré ses parts à la menace d'un
match 3 go mais là faut peut-être jouer
genre un petit fou c'est si c'est un
coup de fouet genre pour essayer de
faire des 4
non mais si nul ne sait si c'est un
petit coup de fouet à ce que tu mets à
soit 4,6 c'est pour ça que j'emploie le
mot fouine tu viens tu viens fouiner
fois à 4 way il faut à 4 les rater une
fouine non ouais mais bon c'est pas fini
pour les mêmes sur métaux récupérateur
de rigoles est une fouine avec des
quatre aussi d'ailleurs
non mesdames ou la dame b 2 ça va condé
n'a jamais existé en échec on reprend d
un cahier d un voire deux pour la
qualité ça va quoi ta d'atteindre goût
c'était mieux avant évidemment ils
abandonnent blanc mesnil matin à 11h
positionnelle que même avec des mois
maintenant ce n'est pas encore fini au
gaz et loire les ébauches appauvri
points dans ta position
en fait j'ai peur qu'ils écoutent le
stream en fait ce qui peut arriver on
n'est plus ce que c'est assez fouinant
tous qui joue va
en 90 quel résultat simultanées j'avais
tout bien
vingt deux parties avec pour rembourser
d'autres je parle 50 ou 25 ans et
comptant les joueurs qui étaient des
objets contre un grand maître quoi il
est apte tremblotant j'espère soirée
plaisir en tout cas et puis voilà on
fera notre foi agadir le pas souvent car
souvent j'étais là en janvier dernier
pour nous et dans tout ça j'étais encore
là en fait pourquoi tu étais allé pour
le nouvel an a gagné un match et je ne
crois pas mais bon il a pas d'idées pas
c'est juste je voulais me faire telles
que ma part du playboy mais est en fait
après je l'écouté voire trois semaines
de vacances mais tu as réalisé ce soir
là c'est pas juste nouvel antre par mais
peut-être fou et 4 la regarde toujours
autan reprend des cas pourquoi pas ne
pas s'isoler et donc est ce que j'ai vu
lors des vacances et puis après
évangélique gibraltar c'est pas idiot
thomas à gibraltar jour la roto
fréquemment et que portugal quoi c'est
sur la route sur bollywood c'est une une
chanson de de palma non sur la route
force avec la tour 8 quand même [ __ ]
c'est pas ça s'est très vite pourquoi
eux deux mais ce que je sais ce que je
sais sur quoi je pensais aussi en fait
mais ça va quand même tu fais tout
projet 6 pour prendre un projet citoyen
je veux le montrer
oula les retournant situation il de
melun parle c'est fini nouveau patron
ouais c'est fouine est né faut pas
croire une pour clouer va s'élever tout
pas semblé de cette tour ne partira
nulle part dont il faut adapter' geste
juste acheté à tour de tours et 4 c'est
pareil c'est un coup de fouet de la mort
windham price est mia pas le permettent
mais tout retour j'essaie de l'arrivée a
tenté jusqu'au bout quoi du bon sauvage
tupper on avait choisi je pense à la
bonne partie de la ronde
taj à la voirie coup contre goody miss
médicis au dessus de sueur se fasse
porter vallier que des galères bon alors
on garde une ligne ou propositions elop
ouais mais oui oui coup il joue vite de
malus écrit qu aime beaucoup et rick
hansen dg toi moi je serai tour d un
personnel ont tendu un tour d'essai pour
s'activer à fond ou tour c'est un tour
c'est cette maintenant le tour c'est 8
mais larry coup il utilise taux trop de
temps là faut qu'il rejoue vu qu'à
rallier les trois quarts et f5 mais bon
cette fournée qui a aidé six cavaliers
prend mais ya rien c'est beaucoup mûri
f4 f5
il aura manqué un peu de temps il aurait
été un poil en a pas mal joué quand même
vous avez des parties serrées
c est chaud là j'ai peur que ce soit les
noirs qui gagne avec le temps va tout va
this way mais bon on regarde le temps
qui perd six c'est chose rare par 3 0
n'at-on pas cinq ou six rondes
si on regarde cette biche happy to fait
on n'a pas vu il a un sur deux boom des
cas parce que ça vachement va en fait
vous faisions de négation et je le
respecte pas mais attends on va voir
laissons une chance mais oui c'est
décevant à la base a abandonné curé de
la partie précédente adversaire c'est ce
qu'on a vu qu'on qui vient de tomber je
crois paris veut des blessures ne
tombait bien marché aux puces et un pour
voir l'histoire si c'était pas ça quitte
à déprimer pensez vous qu'on triche au
petit toutou prépare sur b3 à b2 ou et
des gaffes et qu'est ce que c'est que ça
un ami des chats vidéos et écrit bout il
13h01 chapiteau des captures plus
d'autres béthouart deux adversaires
paralysé kwachas partie de chasse aux
puces un je veux vraiment voir ce que ça
donne
bon que se passe-t-il
assis sur un axe a mis en pl est chasse
aux puces cera kat dégage mais j'aime
bien quand le mec fait à six que je
comprends pas trop ce qu'il veut faire
tuer à 4 aussi on sait jamais quoi la
défausse d'affaires compte des 5 ou bien
d'aller voir et épaisseur à 4 à ce
moment là on était trois à quatre pattes
et bouillon ça manque pas parce que tu
donnes la claque à spectacle avec le
pion c3 que peut-être faire à 5 qui a
validé deux cas et c'est 4 qui est ici
ça m'en veux un peu plus les membres
or d'autres choses comme dans la petite
étoile
c
oula peut-être fois f4 fouache deux
dents à la magnus et martigny offerte à
toujours bien sa vis des six c'est
intéressant ça se développe il est bien
là mais pas le président 24mas jeu c'est
un bon plan la précarité de cailly c4 et
j'aurais quand même sorti le fou avant
ces faits
depuis lors il en va de même sur khalid
sekkat peut encore faire des cinq après
en fait bon dosage
ouais mais bon peut-être faut faire des
cinq pour éviter peut-être un peu fins
six titres ont qualifié quatre fois f 4
à 5 et b6 tête maintenant et mais
peut-être qu'il y ait des cinq tâches et
fougueux quatre amis ian kelly à rester
en l'air tout à fait se sautent pas bon
même voix et c'est le set au pire
turblin et dégage c'est vous qui haïssez
4 car il est des cinq pas se faire car
lieu 3 après mais aurait kf4 d'être né
fouet fin juin retour recyclé
et mon cartable et 6 sauver sa tête est
un des ascensions piémont chante moi ça
fait cinq ans qu'on a essayé de faire
des soldes des cartes attaque benzema si
l'ordre à réagir les droits
tu ferais prises des 5 ouais non je
pensais juste à faire prises avec 5,5 en
fait vous devrez pas vraiment désolé je
vois pas l'idée non je pense juste que
f4 l'a bien jouer au foot et même si ce
mot qui était sur ce vol est frustré par
la suite un prêt d'un match 4 c'est
peut-être rendez vous ici
ok je transforme de la dame et emin
d'arâches 4 mais là cette fois qu'il
veut vous perdez 5
d'après ce que je pense comprendre c'est
dommage car j'aime mieux mais on aime ça
avec madame h 400 et égrène plus fort
cher fois que jessica hay g5 direct
schéma très classique d'attaquer les
bureaux hqe a passé les cailloux 5 kg
4,60 et des écailles et si tu portes la
prise et tu m'as tu vu caisse noire
il faut être quatre sets par à jouer
parce que la dame elle s'en va peut-être
maintenant cavalier 5 du coup sûr
peut-être fait cavalier 5 c'est pour
essayer d'y aller à la brutale quoi je
travaille au sein que j'aurais été
brutale ou une fois d'attaquer les six
bien vu mieux
nous le devons aux quatre ans et demi en
france 3 vous prend et fuit depuis en
france et 2 ans de 3 ok mais le temps le
temps toujours el tiempo
et si et si fabien situe escrito hainan
skype
discussion par en espagnol serait
qu'elle est très vite coupé quoi c'est
même pas légale en fait ça n'existe pas
tant qu'on ne les ait pas ou des gares
des choses et fayard comme un lâche
quattro et ashton kutcher fan de ray est
toujours porquet je prends pas ce qu'ils
font en fait balle et noir il sa valise
stabilise avec des blancs entre une idée
aurait dit pas si sa force des pions
donc là encore c'est un des trois
secteurs comme blanc mais le roi d'abord
un choix bien jusqu'à atteindre un
premier temps et sur h4 30th 5 1 tout
bêtement je lui propose nul bout voilà
on comprenait pas ce qu'ils aient voilà
ce qu'ils ont bien plus de temps qu'on
se montre de beaucoup
alors peut-être pu faire fut décisif au
5 mai cheval salaces ou les deux mais il
a une bonne position en chasse aux puces
il était bien quoi dommage ces familles
la dame en h4 salle aurait facilité la
tâche des plans bien allons voir terra
terra un terrain gras un terreau à 80
qui est dans la merde qui à s'élancer
icare voilà comme partie sympa je pense
terrain il est mort par deux cavaliers
acat échec mais metz pas si simple de ce
que sur 3 5 km dames 5 ont ramené cinq
dames 5 maintenant c'est chaud c'est
chaud fab gros bonhomme de chemin
annoncé durant l'e3 attention je me mets
sur les agences dame de 5 est derrière
ce coup là j'ai peur d'euros à ces sept
moines en iowa cette dame f4 c'est chaud
un cahier des cinq échecs
quelle distinction youtube en iran c est
quelqu un qui sait pas mais tu as roi
bessette encore ses shows fab portes à
l'automne prochain
bîmes reprendre ce ballon reprend 17
faisable que sur tours d un vous
prendrez un échec pour les chèques ou 3
17 dollars
non j'ai peur qu'ils aient dam des cinq
courses et non simplement la tête d'amd
5 ce que j'allais dire pas encore plus
difficile à main autour c'est d'ailleurs
adam prend 1,8
il y aura dame prend à huit femmes deux
dans des fraudes mais non tu peux faire
rabais 8 et sur des huit dames fouet fin
et chaque fête mais en fait je vais je
regarde ce truc avec fous ces huit
échecs et ou pas mais environ has a
perdu aussi brighton 3,8
qu'est ce que cette seule bombe alors
pour repartir vers 16h17 sarko tomber
s'échauffer d38 là quand même plutôt
parce que je suis roi réussissez à tour
ses six mois d'avancé si ces changements
si ce compresseur il faut aussi sous six
mois il faut aussi se croiser champ de
façon y'a plus rien pour personne
ouais mais tu vas tomber on annonce dame
prend il est changé d'âme
stahl temps des jeux dansés reparti on
peut regarder cette de celle contre 2 ap
ça joue bien à 2100 2200 le cap des 5
scandinave
nous sommes la partie était complètement
dingue et à la précédente
l'annoncé des choses des choses c'est
super chaud donc là on suit ensuite qui
sait ben youssef ou de zapper vaut donc
le match pour le titre peut-être mais ce
soir j'aime pas trop à 4 jours est
plutôt fin à trois personnes w4 h kaboom
respect c'est un poil trop dans l'esprit
non
en streaming fait réfléchir l'adversaire
déjà yuans 42
dans l'autre choc trio tout le monde
sait pas comment comment on fabrique et
noir la sébaste psph théâtre sont que
j'ai 4 par les accents reggae id4car des
trucs comme ça c'est un symbole
thierry castola quoi van bommel ou tu
fais je crois je suis passé pour les 6
10 ans nous a fait le coup
tu croyais à l'hystérie c'est prendre
des droits à tous bon c'est mal joué de
la part des blancs elles vont mieux il
veut d'abord voir pour mater le mont
royal suite je pense très serré puisque
tu es même obligé bouger le roi tu vas
faire cailler b4 en premier ok mais bon
il ya parfois si ce n'est qu'il faut f6
car il a beaucoup neigé sa tâche si les
gants sort des embrouilles façon je
crois je suis tu n'existes pas tous à
narita mais il reste la tâche et ben
c'est parce que sarkozy ce que le geek
avec à lens c'est parce que ce soit
parfait
c'est fou quand tu as acheté
d'interstices teyou quatre dames de 6 je
n'irai jamais calculé aussi ses bons
copains tu reste actif et blesse et à
tomates et des pétards avant tu menaces
auxquelles il fait encore chaud en fait
parce qu'ils échangent pas les dames et
si les noirs font dame prend en fait tu
veux te prendre un truc de fou il un
cavalier deux projets 3 qui veut revenir
vers f5 en fait peut être chiant
non les gros rock sharif ya un truc de
fouiner mais ça marche pas un bonjour à
tous enfin réussi à tout reprend h7 en
fait mais ça marchait pas mais avec
l'idée de faire cailler g3 kf5 et de
maths avec les cavs animé le roi sortant
j'ai 6 ans fait mais là encore la
maigreur c'est sûr qu'il faut faire mais
bon sur aucun fait qui prend des trois
quilles problème à et pas quel problème
de se calquer qui protégerait le méteil
souffert cac et prend des trois
cavaliers cadre du coup sûr grand roque
non ouaip auteurs je sais pas on n'y
croit ça changerait prix elf travail sur
les parties en f4 par des cas c'est pas
si grave où est passé le 6 mai peut-être
première des trois villages stable aussi
que ouais mais tout reprendre et trois
peut-être pas mal bouffe de 20 ha il
comprend les pertes de 3 7% à son look
réussi ce monsieur
comment continuer ça il apporte échoue
prépare à lancer il peut prend il peut
prendre rêve de aussi maintenant non
c'est bon c'est chaud parce qu il ya
tout région prisée tout cas tout rachat
par don est possible que des bandes de
l'autre option
l'autre option c'est au courage cette
fois petit tour à enrôler 5pourquoi de
noël manège saas comme terrain casey 4
cet ours et un pour les blancs il a peur
de bouger une bd up est obligé d'en face
on met au garde à vous
tu vas faire ton courage t'a 3f six mois
les fidèles air forcé et là c'est chaud
bizarre je raye ce qu'on peut faire f 4
avant puis en faisant cavalier h3 et
même s'ils protègent après tu fais g3 et
ouvre vraiment tout devant le roi sylvie
roy mais cette taille de 1 de tout
ouvrir devant le roi adverse
dans ce cas je pense que quand il
revient aux cas tout à fait pas
mais c'est peut-être pas mal ce qu'il a
fait quand même ne pas faire f4 ce que
la loi était dans le problème c'est que
rêve 4 tce pas non mais là c'est chaud
chaud très chaud et il sait trois bouts
mais vraiment l'esprit en fait c'est
l'audace trio juste attaquer à fond je
suis parti qui a eu quatre maintenant
mais bon c'est chaud donc je crois
qu'ils sont fils ou neveux par kg 3
quand même donc la double voie tous les
jours mais chez tm est l'hôte il est
dans l'esprit à fond il va refaire à
leurs maîtres l'autre qu'ayant c5 et
alec menacé tour d un tour c'est un
match quoi enfin autour d un tour à un
matt 1 il revient que l'autre gens les
gens avaient pu réutiliser le cavalier
d'aider cette façon sur la faune dans
l'esprit montpetit l'histoire de ce
c'est sûr qu'un magnifique tour français
cette vie vous permettez moi ce que
donnait j'étais un peu pénible bien
passé de ça on s'essaie à apprendre
c'est cette façon c'est sûr d'autres
hackers baisse est plus qu on aura pas
pour les blancs mieux mais bon apple
monte à bord d'assurance vont mieux
j'étais gamine à la djt toi tu vas faire
blé si si si vraiment il ya peut-être
tour f 7 qui est un peu pays veut
revenir vers f6 peut-être faute à
l'envers profité pour faire cavalier 8,6
et allait s'activer à mort je sais pas
comment qui avait pratiqué ces 5 2
je ne sais pas pourquoi son congé et il
n'est pas content mais ma tendresse que
faire droit à ces quatre ab3 en fait
intervient jours bon ça c'est bizarre tu
es roncq à ce que j'allais dire et
j'allais dire pareil marc antoine est
rentrée dès qu'elle est désolidarisée
donc un bon des séjours comme une partie
des têtes retour c'est sec le retour en
fait je voyais un math marrant j'ai
appris que fait-on ses trois échecs 3e 2
tours 3 échecs froide et un tour et un
mac tu vois il peut prendre deux langues
oui il aurait pu mais juste j'ai regardé
bornes pour rigoler oui j'ai vu après
qu'ils pouvaient prendre f2p êtes
cavalli j'ai un échec maintenant
tu chasses que le jeu soit ouvert je
suis athée trois points f2 quand tu pars
qu'elle prend 1,5 et 2 la présidente a
apporté plus de nouvelles portes non aux
données c'est pétillant la production
l'a quand même pour aller à blâmer mais
là ils poussent là quel point il faut
prendre la croix j'ai un nom mais c'est
chaud encore il ya la pendule et où des
données mais face fallait donner le truc
est prêt move comme un idiot en fait
j'ai passés par mon difficile quand même
c'était chaud alors qu'ils ont suis
peut-être bitchage opus contrechoc bits
ou parce qu'on les hait chasse aux puces
sont là on l'a vu dans une défaite un
peu dommage faibli chaabi tout du coup
un bon le mauvais quatre essais pour
il ya vu sa victoire un peu facile pour
kingsburg mini jeux blancs sur le sac de
toujours aimé les chevaux ils pensaient
pas que les stream d'échec matin j'ai
peut-être envoyer le villaret de la
chaîne youtube qui veut venir nous voir
sur youtube
sessegnon qui sinon peu de chance
youtube j'envoie le lien cieux venir
nous suivre je peux venir à tout moment
tu as tout un tas de vidéos de partout
des anciens live ont fait feu de tout
bois
pourquoi l'ordinateur ils appellent ça
la variante rosso limo de la moderne et
micheline moi tout est dit à l'ap in un
niveau de confort mais moi et mes moyens
ni c'est une défense moderne variante va
rentrer au sol immo donc compter que
sont donc à u17 en sommes nous le 5 et
les gars moi j'aime bien le 5-1 idecaf
dégainer 7 c'est aussi pénible
les pressions et les empêche pas de
faire 5-4 mais de façon souvent dans les
pires cavaliers quoi pour défendre des
oasis ne sais pas c'est pas si mauvaise
c'est par 8 est ce que comme coussin ils
vont une bobo n'a que faire avec les
blancs tu joues avec grand roque et h4
du blues genre seront constitués
sans que le risque de chasse aux puces
est née dans l'esprit
les bons esprits à fond des cales mais
du coup c'est choquant position juste à
5 c'est pas j'aime par andy pour envoyer
les pions contre le roi mais en fait
avec l'a5 tu fais quoi
ouattara dessins et des filins pion aux
troupes de colombo un peu car dans un
ben coleman des fois faire b 5 à 6 si
l'objet de prendre du plomb la seule
chez ba ça va être long mais la f3 g4
faut faire marrakech troisième panne
plus bas du coup là ça serait équilibre
un peu peut-être faire foucher 5 avec
les blancs là et s'organiser pour un
faire f 3 après qu'adam des parties
communes emploi auquel fois restent
minces sur train de voir et c'est que
québec
le problème est qu'il est sain qu'est ce
qu'on fait à faire vous aimez cinq là on
va menacer cavaliers en f3 quand après
des études longues et 6 pour percer 6
à vrai dire peu du coup remontée forte
que tu vécu les quatre bons repères
locaux à 4,04 à trois ans mais il avait
bien des grenades ont préparé une c5 un
jour quoi mais là faut dire que 2,5 et
les cas toujours possible nous que pas
faire à 4 est sûre à froid faire genre
damas est en premier pour ramener la
dame en b 6
bon je suis pas sûr
non mais là je pense qu'il faut faire à
trois quand même pour les blancs non tu
penses de ce côté suisse et y faire à
droite je peux faire toujours b3 mais
juste j'aime pas trop le fait que le
calice et 3 soit en prise et la
diagonale et où les écoles et aux nobles
c'est chiant ce qu'il fait à 3 toujours
des fois non plus a pas trop de
coordination à 3 fin même sérail le
carillon b3 tu t'en fous de ce cahier
envie de quoi il sert à rien en fait je
pense sur avec les noirs faire faut
faire de 5 mètres le camion des cats et
poussé b5 en force après chose comme ça
le tour tout comme un fou
on va faire à 3 tempo avec les noirs sur
un 3g fort des trois fois logique et
alors soit en attente et ses 6 d'avancé
sur aix ne fait que 5 des gens car
dessin et us otan des quatre en cas de
prise puis on prend que j'avais des
trois tuile tombe monde entier météo la
raison non mais c'est mal du tout perdre
pour les blancs assez chaud mais avant
d'accéder à 5 avec à bout de la 3e ou
encore mais là on peut pas faire même
mike les blancs essayé cavaliers un dut
vous taisez pourquoi
mais quelle est la seule voix c'était
bien deux attaques secteur fortement la
relation s'est pas fait à 3 et tu fais
c'est sain et fait tout ce que tu
faisais tout avec tembo c'est un beau
bon pas concevable et jusqu'à une once
essonne meaux kenza aurait ce moment
c'est juste une fois on passait en est
de même du foot car il pourra revenir
cinq chiens c'est un très bon esprit je
rêve 3 puis on prend des cations frange
des quatre français trois options
français 3 km à 6 ça sent bon pour les
blancs il va menacer des cinq mais bon
on te rappeler de temps de faire du foie
six mois j'avais quand même fait f3 du
coup en partie pour partie mais bon le
champion prend des cas tu peux faire
cailler b5 intermédiaire bloc
si on prend des coups et b5 puis on
prend des 4e et 5e attaque lucas et b4
aussi nouvelles attaques une porsche ou
stocker les trois fois il va vous
prendre 3 et d'un premier 4e
tu avais rien du tout quoi du coup pour
la libération mais n'avons peut-être 6 e
5 puis on prend 1,5 et puis on prend ces
cinq autres noches opus la formule
mais bon ça reste choquant position mais
doté d'intéressantes seul il fait des
trucs à améliorer un peu mais y avait il
ya du jeu
c'est chaud
je pense aux puces assure qu'il va
tomber
boum ça c'est mon gros tempo et ses 6
contres direz vous et je crois que kiev
15 mai khai trois ou quatre roues via
les points qui restent sans rien n'est
calé impulsion messi juste d'apprendre
et cassation formé quatre est le parti
brokers comme les chaumes du tour lors
d'un probable aux banques de même pas en
fait sept fosses bâton et il préfère
abandonner alors il ya 2 ap contre oscar
11 et 2 ap il n'est pas très bien mais
là je sais pas ce qu'il a fait notre ami
notre ami oscar il a fait un peu la même
erreur qu'on voit gd chez les amateurs
toujours en fait il a laissé le roi de
verre s'activent à fond et ce n'est pas
si grave
mais fatiguée par quoi ils font tous la
terreur jeu c'est pas beau ça répète ça
prend un jaune à là il a vu de données
la partie fait laver une pièce de plus
il a juste perdu une tour est un fou
contre un pion quoi on ferait par fuji 1
à l'égal des réunions et il a du ballon
ou coup de revoir vos droits et
normalement c'est nul car s44 avancée
mais s'ils attaquent le vous fout des
cas foutez vous c5 et non assise ça va
déjà prendre un échec en a vu deux
vous êtes fous des quatre sets 3 6 7 2 7
décembre à b5 nul à wembley et trois
fois même position mais ça a été très
très beau quand même mort mais ouais
enfin je sais pas pourquoi j c il
fallait il fallait mettre le [ __ ]
paraît trop belle de rouen tours avant
de plus que la toxine hommes
alors on va voir groucha contre la belge
8 bits ricky les joueurs écoutent à fond
le live c'est juste chiant
parfois il dit ça en fait elisa le
vitrier pas contents mais as-tu portes
étaient adversaires mais bon ça on
regarde pas souvent les mêmes joueurs en
fait donc hop au bâton ça peut arriver
au maximum une fois dans le tournoi
mais après un petit lapin au moment où
nous on part en direct on entend
également des cadavres dizaine d'autres
angles il ya un petit décalage en
puissance et donc jeudi prochain pour le
live de dudu prochain jeudi on sera
ensemble fab
donc on fera pas des beats à quatre où
je sais pas ce qu'on fera une idée si
les bus tout chaud 7h02 team où chacun
que nous sommes chacun comme le truc
kasparov au pot
d'ailleurs peut-être qu'on peut se faire
le live et une caméra parce que c'est
possible mais c'est sur un vrai chic et
et mon but comme ça très difficile à
organiser
parce que tu peux envoyer le flux live
tu peux utiliser qu'une webcam avec une
webcam t'as pas une bonne qualité pour
ça il faut arrêter quelqu'un qui met les
coûts et qu'ils soient sur l'ordinateur
pour pour mettre l'échiquier verts et
faire les coûts donne des combinaisons
classiques ont vidé de pas si compliqué
de sa nouvelle et où l'on mène aux
joueurs il joue quoi honnêtement tout
roman
à
alors cette partie sud ont regardé en
fait le score de perpignan les
perpignanais contre les dacquois et des
quatre les marches de classiques des
attaques devant prix il a fait la même
couleur a marqué les esprits thater un
marché aux puces h théâtre
ils attaquent comme sa classe et un
schéma très normal dame voilà je peux
enfin je crois qu'aujourd'hui plus
compter d'eau mais que faire quand les
quatre étrangers deux ans fait en poule
2 de relais vidéo mais tu veux pas
prendre envers mais si tu projets dans
premier ouvrage 3 pour défendre
attention des sacs à f4 là mais tout
reprend f4 au meilleur c'est grâce à
tout reprend que ça marche
attention on se bat pour jeu mais vous
vous cachez moi c'est pas si clair
google buzz autour de ravages de roide
trois programmes adaptés droite quand on
va le rouge se trouve à me faisait bien
pour l'évent 3 dépasse c'est le terme
adapté les salaires versés en fait
matériel encore à du matériel en plus tu
peux faire un homme têtu d'horreur h 5
km dames mais y aurait peut-être eu tout
rachat mary kate moss un double échec et
voisins double échec et j'ai pas ces
choix là il ya les rois jitrois aussi
jouable sur barrages 5 fallait qu'ils
venaient s'était rallié sur damage de
roy projet carte quand je monte h 5 3 et
la couperose j'étais obligé de prendre
un
on se reprendre et faire tout point est
fait un nom et pourquoi ils font pas
long mais ok c'est pas fini foot.fr roi
prenait fin le roi se barre ben c'est
bien de tête côté nord mais bon ouais
mais jordan brand and they had apprend
g4 n'était pas case à chocs est le fou
fou et donc magasin phare point fort pat
a pigé deuxièmement on ne vous voit pas
tout bord neuf mais en fait c'est la
même mais sauf que les noirs ou les
blancs auront affronté cinq en fait ce
sont pour affronter obligé parce que
d'un premier pas mal de maths et après
avoir mais tête les noms peuvent juste
faire kg on prend 1,5 en fait eric
vivion tu peux faire rager de roy g3 je
me demandais sauce calcul mais je pense
que oui rachid kg catégorie g3 un truc
cool énorme attaque la plus ratée mais
bon je garde quand même les dames et non
pas terrible donc ok c'est thomas hirth
rouler sur des 3d 2 826 clouage cette
lettre ou tata sécurité en cellule je
veux toi que la contre attaque les lois
méchant 3d ne faut faire l'un
après peut-être même dame à chaque fois
en fait écrit de partout quoi quoi mais
guillou ce que tu as écrit en fait ce
que c'est pas marrant si bon
explique-nous tête d'amgen dans les
coûts marrant mais il y aurait qu un
relief 3d sans sac loué le pion non mais
en fait je préférerais faire dame h 1 si
on prend un f4 et tour g1 mais pierrot
ces deux on s'en va comme vraiment gesta
pourquoi pas mais détroit pour défendre
on croise et de à nouveau
c'est chaud
e
tel fut le cas trop si c'était possible
laïque et français quatre échecs ou
cavaliers f3 taquet français 4 mieux sur
cavaliers 5 à 3 et peut-être fou prend
f3 est fou prend 2,2 pas quoique y
accueille pointe et rien qu'à et froid
doivent être plus forts en fait non mais
quelle france mais juste juste une dame
sans rien donner en fait ce que vous
prend et droiture prix cahier l'âge de
f3 et puis tu gardais tout reprend 1,2
pour le prochain l'un qui est français 4
après l'abandonner je sais pas en france
et devra apprendre à ce qu'elle était
mais bon après il met peut-être du c6 et
ou messages ou encore non à l'or à temps
est-ce que alors 2 a pas gagné alors
peut-être finir par terra concept de
saint vallier une énorme différence vélo
du coup ça donne envie de regarder avec
celle de seb contre terre alors fait un
an je fus c'est chaud attend ton des 2
de damages cas ce que j'allais dire et
dames c4 est d'amener dame ckt je fais
perdre à non tu peux faire dame des cinq
jeunes hommes ont alors marqué trois
points qu'on avait quand même lucides
mais attends tu veux faire tourcoing et
fita non tu peux pas payer chaque que tu
peux aussi quand un truc de fouine sera
chaude dans la chatte progressisme monte
à la volée plus puissante et la finale
va être gagnante
cette source a gagné pour que la
réussite soit 6,6 je crois que l'udc et
des chats
mais auquel la finale bien sûr j'aurais
fait tempo d'un t5 et cheikh ba ouais tu
prends un peu nos affiches sur le voir
lui même attend je peux pas faire avec
les bios maintenant je peux plus le
faire j'aurais pu faire tous reçu
rouages 7
là il ya plus qu adam des cinq marins
mais quand madame étant c4 les tours eu
encore et c'est pourquoi j'ai pu j'ai
raté mais aussi d'un point fr j'ai
oublié en fait ah mais moi je vais faire
un qu'adam ans et 4 c'est pour ça mais
c'est chaud les jolies je lui ai dit
combien il joue à fond dans l'esprit 1
mais je pense qu'il est passé par une
phase difficile dans la partie est du
coup où on a plein coeur de la paix
c'est sur six bravo c'est des hôtels et
des ces 16es ex-aequo avec un peu vite
quoi oui voilà un bon départ ça vous a
le plus merci à ceux qui ont participé
aux gens présents sur le stream avec mon
épaule droite des deux peut-être la
partie d'avant je dis plutôt exactement
tête gtau de chatham en voilà n'hésitez
pas à venir nous rejoindre sur bitstream
sur youtube par exemple les petites
annonces on fait toujours les masters
platon porte électif il aura deux ans -
pouvait lire sur le site de quelle vidéo
au pluriel
mais pékin a subi deux échecs points
comme c'est ça ouais ouais voilà on peut
le voir mener de master class ou qui
auront mieux donc
je suis pas je suis plus et d'approuver
16-17 mans 17 minutes jeudi 17 18 heures
et puis nous on se retrouve bientôt ça
qu'elle vend deux jours il sera là comme
aura donc on sera sur le même écran sera
plus séparer cette fois ouais mais on
fera les faits on essaiera de faire des
vidéos si on a le temps après vidéo du
blog il sera peut-être jeu sortira dans
plus longtemps le blog je pense que ça
on verra comment on se débrouille on
verra mais on essaiera peut-être enfin
déjà samedi j'ai déjà la vidéo de cartes
scène laura bon coeur à une vidéo samedi
déjà ça c'est sûr oui là aujourd'hui
elle title tu sais qui est sorti suis
qui s'est joué mardi dernier donc
donc on a on a des vidéos il va il va
sortir des minots même quand on est au
maroc en fait ya tout le temps des
vidéos qui sortent depuis depuis deux
ans fab jamais jamais trop têtu peut
toujours suivre tout le temps tout en
tout temps que le truc ne meurent jamais
ce fantastique quand même quand il pense
même espace que des vidéos de rap
d'abord où on voit débouler matin le
prêt serait convenable programme très
chargé et toi et moi si tu pars un peu
droite à gauche aussi j'aurais australie
nouvelle zélande
la mission est plus frais en vacances
quand j'allais je serai bien bon on
l'est on vous laisse on souhaite une
bonne série de chalon